[Music]
all right here we go slated trs 30th
panel take one
oh
oh
totally got me
hey i'm george campbell and i want to
help people spend less save more so they
can live a life with more freedom
basically i want to help people suck
less with money hey my name's ken
coleman and i help men and women
discover and do the work that they were
created to do hey guys i'm rachel cruz
and i love helping people get in control
of their money and create a life that
they love hey what's up my name is john
deloney i sit with people who are
struggling to figure out the next right
step for them hi i'm christina ellis i
love to help people figure out how to
pay for their educations debt-free and
win with money hey i'm dave ramsey i've
spent the last 30 years of my life
helping people get out of debt
become wealthy
and become outrageously generous
so we're here celebrating 30 years of
the ramsay show dave you've had a lot of
success over the years best-selling
author many times over over 600 radio
affiliates 18 million listeners three
hours of radio for 30 years are you
tired
[Laughter]
no i'm fine okay life is good well take
us back because it's easy to forget that
it didn't start this massive and this
big headquarters and big shows and all
these team members take us back to where
it started well there was a um
a radio station in nashville
that was in bankruptcy
and um
i went on a friend of mine that was a
real estate guy had had a show
that was pretty much like a bad saturday
night live skit like bad talk radio
that's if you did a saturday night
that's what it looked like only he was
serious about it it was just bad
and they had no
staffing they were in bankruptcy so he
answered his own phones
and um live on the air live on the air
and no screening how does that work uh
not well but um
so anyway i went on the show and we were
talking about real estate and i had this
we were in this real estate club and
trying to get people to come visit the
club with the speaker coming to town and
that kind of thing and then towards the
end of it he goes so uh you know
what are you doing these days i said
well i'm helping people that have you
know
had trouble financially and he goes well
if you've had trouble financially just
call in right now
and if you're struggling and the phone
rang and he wasn't used to the phone
ringing much and kind of scared him and
so he's like uh you're on the air and
some guy whose car was in repo and was
crying and right there and so we
answered the call and somebody else
called and we answered the question and
and he wasn't used to getting that kind
of action on the air it was
because it's bad and
he goes hey man come back let's do this
again that that kind of worked and i
went okay so i did it a couple more
times and then
a a friend of mine
uh in the mutual fund business at the
time
uh called me and said uh the guy that
you run a show quit they're paying him
35 a day or something and his check
didn't clear in bankruptcy and he goes
we got to go do that show and i went i'm
not doing radio
radio people don't get paid nothing
they're like bankers big egos and titles
and no money i need money i am broke my
kids are hungry i'm not doing this he
goes hey man we got to go do that show
he goes you could do it a couple days a
week i could do it a couple days a week
i'd get leads for my mutual fund
business and who knows you might even
sell some that stupid little book you
wrote
and that was financial peace that was
financial peace carrying it around the
trunk of my car wow we're all so nervous
like i could only imagine not doing
anything
like now you're used to like right we're
we do we want radio and all of that yeah
oh we were and we were bad were you
nervous though yeah but we were bad
it was it was awful did you know you're
awful yeah yeah no y'all probably
thought you were great
well you mean there's part of you but i
mean we were we were cheesy but we were
country fried accents and i later got a
coach a voice coach and
but it was like wwtn we're talking nice
feel y'all call in y'all game money
questions it was hillbilly
redneck radio i remember being little
and driving through downtown nashville
with the and the billboards started
going up yeah you had a milk mustache
yep there was like there was a tampon
called got milk it was like all over
nashville there was a campaign called
got milk that was popular yes 30 years
ago and um all these celebrities with
their milk mustache and it was kind of a
passive aggressive question got milk and
so goddamn uh we said got debt and put
milk mustaches on
and the scissors and all of it it's
great but good imagery though
was this back in the money game days
cause the transition it was a money game
from day one that's what it was called
when did it transition to the dave
ramsey show
um
we had uh started syndicating the show
and the guy that was on with me left and
there was another guy working on fridays
who
they fired him the radio station
wouldn't let him keep going because he
started doing politics stuff
and so i end up
last man standing doing the show and we
were trying to syndicate it doing
marketing nationally with the money game
the money game the money game the money
game and uh laura schlesinger dr laura
was blowing up she was getting huge we
had about 30 stations or 40 stations at
the time and rush was of course huge and
sean was blowing up hannity was blowing
up for the first time
um
and so
you know
we actually had a great marketing guy
there's a friend of ours come in and go
you're you know you're killing me here
rush does not have the political game dr
lara does not have the relationship game
people are having trouble figuring out
there's too many things going on with
this brand you need to just bring it to
the dave ramsey show you need to brand
everything off of dave ramsey we shifted
everything today ramsey branding off the
single person brand
and then everything drove through that
brand that and that focus is what helped
us move everything events books websites
are working it was in the early days of
the web and
um this whole place was built on you and
your personality so what point did you
go okay this can't just be about me
forever we've got to bring in more
voices to carry this message at what
point did you start thinking about that
and taking action
about 15 years ago in my mid-40s i said
um
you know this thing's not going to
outlive me if i if we don't
decide how we're going to carry the
message in the next generation and as we
started thinking about that we said well
we don't really say anything that's
unique
lots of people have said live on less
than you make get on a budget you know
lots of articles were boring written by
boring financial people and
the only thing that's unique is
that we actually love the people we
actually care about people and we're
actually helping them and we've got
compassion for them and we're sassy and
smartely and funny and tell stories and
entertaining and
convince them in the midst of that to go
through their transformation so we
realized at that point that the business
the whole thing we built would just die
with me
if we didn't have other people that
could do the same thing that could love
people well engage them be smart smart
alec uh loving compassionate whatever it
took bold whatever it took in the moment
to do not only good radio but be good on
the stage be thought leaders in their
space
um and so we started with the idea of
bringing other people on and
you know we discussed uh
for a hot minute just it being rachel
but the more we looked at that that
would be
uh unfair
to her
uh to to dump the weight of the whole
thing on one person number one and then
number two we couldn't find anywhere
where the single follow-up the single
brand following the brand had worked we
hardly couldn't find any things that
anything it worked but
uh god kind of spoke to us and said you
know um
it's a one-to-many hand-off not a
one-to-one hand-off
and so that's how you are here we sit
thank you thank you guys i'm so glad
you're welcome about all you're here
you're really wimped out abby lays the
crown
yeah how do you how do you guys sum up
what the ramsay show is like if you're
talking to a stranger on the street and
they're like what's the ramsay show how
would you all describe it i would say
it's a place that people call in with
their questions about their life and
it's it's more heavily geared towards
money um
but yeah it's just a couple of people
sitting in a radio
studio friends
and taking people's calls
i think there was a there's like a
simplicity in mind if you remember i'm
gonna butcher it uh possibly but i think
many years ago
this tagline of the show was like where
real life happens call after caller what
happens caller after calling and i i
think
even that's an older moniker i think
that's actually still extremely relevant
we're kind of diving into whatever mess
is going on and you know
life and going here's how we think we
can help well you know it doesn't matter
what the topic is that caller is calling
in in that moment going i i need some
help i mean you think about the dynamic
for someone to call into a live show and
we're all weird you know we're a small
sliver of the population that doesn't
freak out when you're in front of people
i mean most people really do fear public
speaking more than death and so the
pressure for someone to call in live on
the air and talk to somebody that's
that's a terrifying proposition for a
lot of people so there's that
and then they're dealing with something
where they go i this is i feel like i
need a breakthrough and so regardless of
the topic like rachel said it's just
real a real person with a real struggle
who needs real help i i remember the
first couple of calls i took
on
my podcast and it came out organically
my first my first response to their
question was why are you calling me
and like that's a huge thing why haven't
you called your friends or your pastor
or your family members and to a person
every response was
dude i got nobody yeah like you're the
only person to call and so if you had
asked me right when i was starting what
is the role of this show like how do i
explain it i would say it's a show
people call that life
now i've i think my answer would be
different it's we'll be there
it's a call we when when you've got
nobody we'll be honest with you and
we'll tell you what we think we think
we're pretty smart we think we know what
we're talking about but we'll be honest
with you and i think that there's a lack
of
people who will be honest with you and
not try to play some games with you and
just say here's what i would do in your
situation and i think we're just missing
that yeah i also think it's just like a
safe space like these topics we talk
about sometimes there's stigma around
them people feel shame and they feel
intimidated to talk to their friends and
family and it's like this is a spot
where we're comfortable with this like
you can bring us your ugly stuff you can
bring us the things that you don't want
to mention to anyone else and we'll work
through it we'll celebrate with you the
things no one else will celebrate well
that and the within the first 30 seconds
of most calls okay how much money do you
make how much debt do you have and like
you're not going to just like tell your
bff
you're like that's kind of personal
information but i'll tell these
strangers on the phone because there's
no and that's the beauty i'm like
there's no emotional attachment to us in
a sense
because we're like we're here so you
call we'll hear it all and i'll just you
cut through months
hey i i remember when i was first seeing
um counseling clients in my practicum
they would tell me all kinds of things
about their intimate life about their
relationships what they failed at they
would not tell me how much they made
they wouldn't how much debt they have
and it's so funny it's like hey my name
is tom how much do you make and how much
debt you got i mean we're like right
through that man and we've changed
people's names how much of that's credit
card debt tom exactly it looks like
super like you failed unless you play it
all out but i mean i think there's a
level of
the world is desperate for that and you
don't get it anywhere else because
there's we've got to do 17 sessions in
therapy to get to even get to that
question we got to establish trust you
called us
what's the problem let's get rid of it
let's get right into it
dave you built a trust brand do you you
know i i don't take it for granted that
people call in and trust us with their
life's greatest problems is that
something you were intentional about
from day one
or did you kind of go oh people trust me
i got to make sure i handle this well
you know we started out just answering
the tactical question day one and then
we start realizing
wait they
really are opening up
and letting us into the intimate parts
of their life
um
and then they you know they would call
randomly about some marriage thing or
something and i'm like
i can help you with your 401k what are
you doing
and but it started just you know what we
used to call uncle dave or papa dave
started kind of evolving pretty early
even though i was young but it was just
this trusted friend that was wise and
that would you know that seemed to have
just some common sense about life
and um
we started realizing that that was there
and what that is then is a tool to
actually be able to help them because
they're not going to take any advice if
they don't trust you right but i mean
and if you violate that trust if you
uh when you when we violate we we all
goof up yeah when we when we mess up
uh even the smallest of things we don't
you know sometimes we're
compassionate when we should be a little
tougher sometimes we're too tough when
we should have been a little more
compassionate
and um you mess that you mess up the
connectivity and the audience all knows
that i mean it's not just the caller
that gets that message
so then it's a little harder to trust
next time so
uh but but most of the time the audience
has been uh really forgiving
and um at least portions of it the
portions that aren't forgiving are gone
so but then they're listening to
something else but uh you know they they
this you know these people are trying to
help i was on my walk this morning
construction worker my neighborhood
stopped and he goes hey man i'm a
millennial i listen every day i love
your stuff man you're changing lives man
you changed my life thanks so much and
i'm like dude you changed your life i
didn't change your life but i mean that
guy's out there and he's listening to
when i talk to someone else he'll never
be a caller
but great guy yeah but he'll never be a
caller so that trust is built on
consistency over time you're not
wavering in your opinion day for better
and for worse
so talk about some of the foundational
principles
that run throughout the show
uh
it all kind of falls under the umbrella
of be not conformed to this world
but be transformed
by the renewing of your mind
and so we can look out there in any
department compartment
of our lives in society
marriage parenting mental health career
money
you name it at business ethics
leadership we can look into any area out
there and see
the vast majority of people in that
segment are dysfunctional
they're struggling
because
and so you don't want to be normal in
almost any of those categories i just
mentioned you you want to be unusual and
success is unusual so it's while we say
that's why we look and smile when we say
that person's successful they have a
successful marriage and because it's
unusual you know and so
uh the underlying principle is is to
lead them
away from
the dysfunctional normal
to the functional
abnormal
uh in whatever area it is and that's
just truth telling
and again compassion and boldness and
laughter
and stories and tears and
uh
then people trust you and then you can
take them by the hand and lead them to
the next place they need to go
in all of those areas so that's kind of
the underpinning underneath all the
different topics from money and life and
relationships rachel you've been in the
money space for you know a decade now
here at ramsey as a personality what
have you found the common threads the
principles that carry regardless of the
calls
well from the money angle i would say
those underlying principles are
teaching people to live unless they make
which means
getting out of debt staying out of debt
having margin in your life which frees
you up in so many other areas when you
have margin in your bank account you
know the rating day funds like that like
those were those are kind of the tried
and true
and it's funny because it's so simple
right like that's what that's what makes
me laugh about even mind-blowing money
advice right i know that's what's going
on the show is like it's 30 years of
kind of from from especially the
financial perspective the money
perspective
it's the same stuff over and over and
over and over and over and over and
still you'll get people they're like oh
you are so wise i'll never forget one of
my first national hits i was in new york
city doing the morning shows the
on set we were doing the live segment
and i and i made the comment yeah just
you know you have to live on less than
you make because it's something i've
heard my whole life it's what we say
here at rooms all the time it's just
like a and they and these people that
i've watched on like these
these anchors on the show that i very
much look up to in life because i'm like
oh or not look up to you but just i i
watched them in my own house
they looked at me and one of them said
that is so smart
and i was like
she just said i was so smart
i'd live on less than you make like it's
amazing so yeah so i think for us too
like those we're doomed
jesus is coming but no one is saying it
though right like to his point well
there's a system when you're conformed
to the world you're doing what the world
is doing and they're not like on
something so simple of living unless you
make so that's always the bright spot
where i'm like we can we can insert hope
into the culture and it's not confusing
like we don't i mean like we get to
bring out a very simple plan and we get
to talk about the behavior change and
the things that make it difficult but
that's what i love about all the
principles is i'm like
there's not many and they're
pretty simple pretty simple to
understand hard to do sometimes but one
of the things we do in one of the in all
the areas is we take the complex and
make it
reachable
i often tell people in our marketing
team or on air people all the time same
thing put the cookies on a shelf where
everyone can reach the cookies
because in the mental health field we
like to
speak over
financial people like to speak over
career coaches they want to use seventy
thousand dollar words when a when a two
dollar word would have done the job
but it's all in an effort to look
smarter feel smarter build themselves up
rather than communicate connect and help
someone where they are
and so um in that sense we get the joy
of just being regular folk who just
happen you know we don't have to be
hotty toddy we don't have to be you know
better than uh because financial people
do this a lot in the you know in that
world and we're just not those people
we're just
may or may not like us or you may not or
may not agree with us but what we say is
this
simple oh it's doable and it's
life-changing
i think that's part of the reason it's
the second largest talk radio show in
america it just connects with every
american out there we're not using big
10 words like you're saying we try to
keep it really simple and john you've
got two phds that's got to be especially
difficult for you to bring the cookies
down no no
life with hoity-toity one thing that
that i think dave taught me real early
was
i've got
dave's got success he's got his name on
a building um he's got a nice car right
a nice house
and
um
him and his wife still disagree on
things and he's got reckless
children right that's still gone off the
frontier
get off the rails
um
not just his wife disagrees with him
oh geez we can't have a family session
break out
but like i i think there's something
about
a here's the right steps and it's hard
and then i'm gonna go first and i think
that's missing from popular culture and
popular media is if i can just get to
this place then everything's perfect and
everything works out and i can't
identify with that i can't identify the
marriage that nobody has any problems i
can't identify with
i'm out of debt and i'm still going to
have a disagreement with my spouse so
because i want to buy i want to buy that
new guitar so bad and she's like we
don't need another one you don't even
play in a band like i know but i need
that like i want to know that someone's
still having that disagreement or like i
want this new car
we've got you're good on cars nope i
need this one too right
now i can relate to that then i think
there's a human there's a human element
that's like oh that guy's just like me
yeah right our bank accounts may look
different or our business may be
different but that dude's just like me
and i'll follow that guy right this may
sound silly but it's like whenever i'm
talking and i'm thinking through how can
we translate the data and the content
it's like if i were listening to this
would i get bored like would i zone out
and just kind of tune out and if if
that's the case then it's like okay we
gotta bring this down we gotta make this
more relatable because it's like i mean
when i'm reading content that's like way
up here in heady it's like oh they sound
smart but like this is boring yeah and
what am i going to do with it how am i
going to do it how do i apply this to my
life does it matter to me totally
totally
[Applause]
the dumbest thing i've ever done with
money is i let a friend talk me into a
multi-level marketing purifying water
thing that i've never sold and honestly
so stupid the only mowers i got four i
got four mowers the dumbest thing i've
ever done with money i kept paying for a
gym membership for three years because i
told myself i'd go soon and i never did
um i've got three deep freezers those
weren't i've got a problem okay i got a
problem the dumbest thing i ever did
with money was to go deeply in debt
buying a bunch of real estate in my 20s
which caused me to go bankrupt because i
was dumb i once shipped a pair of shoes
on craigslist to nigeria for a guy's
cousin and it was a scam
it's honestly probably when i buy like
expensive designer stuff and then my
wife's like wow
we have two deep freezers why do we have
a third and i'm like here's what i think
i think what's about to happen is
zombies
there's a lot of calls that
are on a spectrum from
hilarious to heartbreaking to strange um
and dave you've had the brunt of this
having taken over uh almost 100 000
calls based on some rough napkin math we
did
i know it's hard to pinpoint some of the
weirdest or funniest moments but are
there any that are burned into your
memory that have become a core memory
for you i i can't help myself i got a
greatest hit request okay because he's
he's walking us right to it you gotta
tell about the call the guy who had the
brilliant idea for the telephone booth
oh god because i feel like this is a
perfect example represents the strange
oh i've i've completely
melted down
on the air and laughter to the point i
couldn't recover
two times in 30 years
i could not get it back you know where
you just get that laugh and you're just
like it won't stop like 13 year old
girls it's the church giggle you're just
a church giggle yeah you can't stop you
can't breathe you can't and the more you
try to
try to get back you can't get back and
so yeah this guy calls in the second
second segment of the show and um and
this is a long time ago because there
were pay phones for those of you don't
know there were these phones we used to
put quarters dimes into and then later
quarters
and you could make a phone call that way
and this guy calls up and says um you
know i figured out how i can get free
phone service in my house and i said
okay how are you gonna do that and he
says
he says i'm gonna put a pay phone in the
house and i'm like uh well somebody's
gotta have the quarters to put in he
goes well i'll furnish the first set of
quarters because when they put the
quarters in then i'll take them out
and give them back to them and they can
put them in again and so i'll get free
phone that sounds like congress and i'm
like
uh
you have to pay for the connection he
told the paper phone phone line and i
started he goes huh and i said when you
put a payphone in your house if it's not
connected with a phone line and i just
started losing it because you're because
you just bought a phone line that you
were trying to not buy and it's just and
i i i
this guy's this guy's dumber than a rock
and i just thought he beat the system
and i just started i just completely
melted down and i mean and you can hear
it in the audio it's just and finally
uh
blake just uh you know he was a producer
he just took it to commercial because i
couldn't get back
we went to commercial early screwed up
the whole network the affiliates were
going bonkers they didn't know what to
do but he just started playing
commercials because there was i was not
coming back
i was thinking of the advisability of
putting in a pay phone
instead of my regular phone service
because for 800
you can get a pay phone
joe that you have to pay for the phone
line still i had a payphone yeah if you
picked if you don't hook the phone line
to the phone
you're not going to have a dalton
okay well that's what i wanted to find
out if there was a hole in this it's
what's called an air gap
[Laughter]
that happened to me once on the air that
i couldn't recover and i had to like
look down and i was just silent the rest
of the segment if i looked up i would
have just started what was it last time
it was on the air with you
and this girl called and she was like
yeah and i can't i cannot remember who
she was or the numbers or anything or
even the story i don't even remember but
it was basically like
you know i have 30 000 in debt and i'm i
can do this thing where i sell this
thing and i'm going to make 120 000 but
i just need to invest
a hundred dollars into this idea and i'm
gonna make all this money and and you
know and i'm
and we're all like okay okay so this and
dave's asking her a few you know
clarifying questions and finally dave
goes
okay sarah where did you get all these
numbers
and it just goes silence goes out of my
butt
they're all laughing oh yeah he's
laughing they all lose it and i'm like
and i was like
but then if you get the laughs and you
can't recover then you're laughing at
the fact i'm laughing and then and then
yeah and i was done well and that the
booth guys got to where they would just
drop below this oh they
because they knew if i was looking at
them laughing it was going to make me
start to lose it and i couldn't my
goodness but i've been able to get
through all of them
how much you gonna charge
uh i was thinking probably like
oh 100 to 200 per room where'd you get
that number
um out of my butt
[Laughter]
well uh
probably i'll do some
more research than that
uh lord of mercy
i'm losing it oh
we used to do a stupid tax hour
and people would call in if you'd done
something stupid with money you lost the
money we called it stupid tax and still
do
and uh the stupid tax stories were
hilarious
i mean a guy calls up and he goes
uh
i said what'd you do that was stupid he
goes i bought a monkey
okay he bought a monkey he goes yeah
spotted nose gwenen
and i'm like
that's a thing a monkey's he goes yeah
it's a big monkey and he goes yeah and i
said okay so he said i thought it would
be a cool pet
and it was kind of a cool pet and then i
started dating this girl and i got
engaged to her and the monkey was
jealous oh boy of my fiance and it would
hit her
and it would poop and throw its poop at
her oh my god and he goes and so i ended
up the he said i paid 2 500 for the
monkey and he goes i ended up having to
give the monkey away i said you gave
away the spotted nose gwen and he's like
yeah anything it was it was just mean it
was just mean it's jealous and mean and
hateful and i had to give it away nobody
would buy it
i bought
a monkey
you didn't i did a spotted nose clinton
it was a spotted nose gwinning yes it's
a type of monkey it was a beautiful
monkey sounds like a girl i went out
with in high school
every time i tried to kiss or hug on my
wife that monkey would try to punch my
wife with its little fist
and bottom line is my wife she just
didn't care for that too much
[Laughter]
you all should bring that segment back
yeah we ought to do the taxes that's why
where are they now i'd like to know
where the money is
and the worst one was the guy that
called on the stupid tax hour this was
the worst of all he goes yeah i spent
seven thousand dollars on my wife to get
breast implants
oh my god and he goes i come home
a week after she's home from the
hospital and i found her in bed with my
boss
and i drug him out in the front yard and
beat him up and the cops came and
arrested me
he said so
i i i put the operation on a credit card
he goes so i got seven thousand dollars
in debt
i got to go to jail i got fired i'm
getting a divorce and i never even
touched those things
oh
we just about lost like an episode of
we're on the floor yes
yeah this could happen on the air you
got to be ready it's live radio oh man
man well for every funny call there's
also some emotional heartbreaking some
intense calls where you know you're in
the middle of a really messy situation
uh any stick out to you guys you're like
this one i still think about mine was
mine was the time
uh i wasn't on the air i there's there's
that bathroom in the dressing room
behind the
recording studio and i just walked by to
use the restroom
and
i waved into the control booth to say hi
to everybody and kelly who was the call
screener associate producer at the time
she had like in the crisis world we call
them crazy eyes when somebody you can
look across the room and know there's a
something bad's going on and she waved
me in and that's when i walked into a
call y'all were a part of that ended up
going for quite a while but there was a
moment
on the phone with that woman i thought i
thought i was going to hear her i
thought i was going to hear her get
killed
um she was just in a real abusive
situation in that moment
yeah she had a boyfriend that was
beating the snot out of her and she's
caught calling us
and he walks in while she's talking
about asking about selling her house she
said i need to move yeah can i move to
get away from him and i'm like no you
need to leave right now like and she
said now i said no right this second go
get your baby get in the car and drive
away do you have family in the area
you've got to get away from this and he
walks in and grabs the baby and starts
holding the baby and
threatening her she goes ends up sitting
in the car because he puts the baby in
the floorboard he's going to drive away
she dives in the back seat of that car
and said she's sitting in there with him
and john's on the phone trying to talk
this guy down well we got the police on
the way yeah and the cops roll up on
bubba and
so bubba which was very intuitive of you
though because i remember because i was
on the air with you on that one and she
called and she's kind of out of breath
even
and she's like okay i just need to know
um
can i sell my house can i and it was
this like urgent seeing her voice
and i think you were the one that were
like okay
why safe right now why are you wanting
to sell your house and she was like well
i just i need to i'm not in a good
situation i'm just not in a good
situation
and you were like where is he is he near
you right i mean and you picked it up
and i mean i kind of was a little bit
more oblivious you zoned right in on it
and man and it was it was like literally
going on on the air of him there and
she's like she's just walked out i mean
it was scary in all fairness kelly said
before we picked up the call she said
there's something going on here you need
to figure it out
she kind of she didn't know what it was
she said something's up and so i i was
digging based on her input it wasn't
okay pure intuition
so are you going to sit there
in the middle of the sewage or are you
going to fix it
i want to fix it that's why i want to
sell my home and i just want to go no no
honey we don't need to call a realtor
we need to get the boyfriend out of the
house and that's going to involve the
police and or your father and your
brothers
he needs to leave it's your house
and you're afraid
you understand that this is wrong right
yes sir okay this is this is you're
you're not the crazy one
i'm talking to the same one you know
what a lot of trains just feels like
that yeah i know
all right i'll tell you what we're gonna
do
we're gonna put you on hold and kelly is
gonna make sure that law enforcement
gets over there okay no sir don't you
please no baby doll
i'm not gonna be i'm i'm not listening
i love you and that baby
do what
just needed to know if i should still
like how to
[Music]
listen listen easy breathe
you're in a horrible situation and you
have to make the moves to get away from
it
but you don't have a financial problem
you need a boyfriend ectomy
[Laughter]
and it's happening today darling
it's happening today
dave there is a level of discernment and
intuition you have i remember listening
before i worked here this american life
did a feature
on you and they were actually digging
into how you can hear things in the
caller's voice and call things out that
the average listener would have no idea
and you go
is he hitting you and they're talking
about some random money question and
they're shocked because you're right how
does that happen well i mean it's an
intimate medium
and the you know where you're just
we don't have a visual you don't have
body language
uh all you've got is voice and the
cadence
in the voice
it's um
in a sense it's like someone who's lost
their sight
because all you're using is one of your
senses
you know you're hearing and so you're
dialed in and
if you just stay focused on what's going
on you can hear it
uh i mean i've heard all of you pick up
on you can tell when somebody's lying
in that setting more than you can in
person i think
because they'll give you the verbal
they'll give you the body language cues
and that kind of thing but their verbals
off
and you can in person they can lie to
you easier but in this you'll hear them
you know that
you go okay so what's going on there and
is this what's happening and
you waited too long to answer yeah
you're having to make up a lie
you waited too long to answer and in
that case on that piece of video or
audio
again i actually had data
that i had i dealt with on one of the
shows i was doing in new york with uh
one of the talk shows with the
psychologist on the thing and she worked
in a domestic violence shelter when she
wasn't working on the show as a
psychologist as a counselor and she said
she showed me the data she said there's
a huge high correlation
between a man who is
extremely overbearing and over
controlling on the money
with him hitting her
so like she can't go to the grocery
store without him going with her
she can't buy a stick of gum without him
he controls everything 1 000
and if it's like the more extreme that
is the higher the probability that
there's domestic violence and so this
lady's like my boyfriend won't let me go
to the grocery store by myself
he wants to he wants to control all the
money and i'm like
so how long has he been hitting you
it's like for her she's like where'd
that come from well i had that piece of
data but you could also hear her voice
that she was you know the way she's the
stress you could feel it in her octave i
mean in her vocal cords coming out and
so we just you know you just go
and the poor little person doing the
interview that was in the studio for
that other show
went we came off there and she was how
did you know that
i'm like i'm magic
[Laughter]
well aside from all the funny and
emotional there's been a cornerstone of
the show for almost as long as we've
been on air which is the debt-free
scream
and uh you know about once an hour we
celebrate someone who's paid off any
amount of debt who went all in following
the baby steps following our plan are
there any debt-free screams that stand
out to you guys it's one of my favorite
parts of the show because you just have
a smile plastered on your face as you
look across the glass and see those
people who traveled from all over the
country or called in to share their
story
you know i think about probably the
heaviest and most uh
painful but beautiful debt-free scream
it was years ago in our uh old building
and it was a sweet mom single mom and
she's up there telling her story
and she just laid out the story of how
her husband died and and it's to this
day i think it remains one of the most
powerful calls but it was one of those
where normally those debt-free screams
are are moments of great celebration and
and it was but as she walked through the
pain of what she went through and how
much it meant to her and how much her
husband had been on the journey and see
those little kids with her so now you
had a single mom who it was
heart-wrenching the loss that she went
through and you look at those kids and
they lost their daddy and
and then you kind of like that's
colliding with the fact that she's there
heartbroken but also celebrating and
grateful for her husband and his role
and it's those crazy moments where it's
so
heavy you know it's like it's like the
funeral that everybody's sad but
everybody's happy you know it's like hey
we know where they are and it's gonna be
okay
but it was those kind of that was
probably the most heavy thing i was just
hosting the video channel back then and
i was standing in the lobby watching
dave do that one and there wasn't a dry
eye in the studio the control room the
lobby and you know those are those are
powerful powerful moments when you
realize what this is all all about
and in two years you paid off your house
yes sir that was
our dream it was our dream
denises and mine to make this happen and
and god is really good all right kids
you guys been practicing the debt-free
stream too
all right all right well this is about
the best one i've had in a while i'll
tell you that thank you sir so uh all
right cynthia count it down ready
three
two one where
oh my gosh
wow
oh
man oh man
thank you lord for work that matters
the one that i remember um stuffed off
my head there's been so many great ones
uh was
dave i think it was you and i that was
doing it and
you always ask the question how'd you
get started on this
and that um
husband was it was a veteran and
he said
i just kind of got to the point where i
need to make sure my family was taken
care of because i was gonna take my life
i decided i'm done and so i need to make
sure everybody's good
and as a part of
i've seen it i need to clear the deck
for my family it's the right thing to do
before i protect my life
and
one of the things that you you
were so instrumental putting in the baby
steps long ago is you can't do this by
yourself you got to sit down with
somebody and so as
as he sat down with his wife
ultimately it came out and then they
started the journey to get his health
taken care of and get his men all taken
care of and ended up with a new job
just the breadth of change that happened
in this family but it started with a guy
sitting down his wife said i'm not doing
okay and so we like
i think you and i we've talked offline
dave you couldn't have dreamed up a
better program for somebody struggling
with significant depression because
i'm going to give you a tiny little goal
meet this thousand bucks just do
whatever you got to do to meet this and
then we're going to meet another goal
and a little goal that's the path out of
so many mental health challenges
relational challenges and the money
challenges and you end up trying to get
out of debt and you end up fixing your
marriage and all and
saving a life you end up doing all this
other stuff that just changes everything
uh about your about about your about
everything change everything about
everything
so what happened let you on fire man you
all went off like fireworks uh honestly
uh it's pretty wild story uh i was
actually debating on whether i should
commit suicide or not
um and i wanted my family to be secure
when i was gone and then just listening
to your show and hearing the bible
verses every day
i came home and talked to tori and
decided we should probably get into a
church
we found river valley up in the twin
cities
and
gave our life to
jesus christ got baptized october 31st
which is kind of a joke and a half
because our favorite holiday was
halloween for a long time
and uh
just changed our life ever since yep
amazing wow so was the financial
pressure part of
that or just other mental issues um
i'm a disabled veteran
so i deal with ptsd and some traumatic
brain injury from from some of that so
wow
wow what's your healing journey been
like
um you know it's uh it's been a process
i i got into a big good group of uh guys
at church uh some men's leadership
courses
um starting counseling with the va
coming up on august 1st so very good
congrats man very good it's awesome
and another one that sticks out to me is
in the old building the gennad family
came to announce they paid off their
house and so we were celebrating them
and they had their kids with them and i
was hosting the video channel at the
time they're grown kids they're grown
kids about my age and this is a middle
eastern family i grew up my my parents
are middle eastern and so there was
already a connection there and they said
hey dave before we do our debt-free
screen we wanted our kids to be
involved we don't we didn't want to do
this without them so we wanted to
surprise them today and let them know
that we've paid off both of their houses
oh my god and i mean we were all just
crying in happy tears it was just such a
shock and that was one of the most
special moments because it made me go
that's the kind of legacy i want to
leave that's the kind of dad i want to
be
and how old are the kids now
they're not kids yeah 29 and 30. okay
and they're well established in this
methodology and
in fact you know if i could i just want
to share something they're also
debt-free with the exception of their
mortgage
um there is uh you know we don't have
any secrets they've been right there
with us
but there's one thing that we've kept
from them and i'd like you to kept
something from this yeah it was a little
secret
let's just keep it to ourselves what
kind of secret are you going to do right
here on the radio and the secret is just
because they're here and they're going
to
scream that free with us we would like
them to know that their mortgages are
paid off
[Applause]
unbelievable
yes
wow
[Applause]
wow
you know we're really clear that the
best thing that we can leave to our kids
is the wisdom to know how to handle
their lives and and um you guys are
changing your family tree big time
one of the interesting things being new
on the show is that having watched debt
free screams for years and then being on
the show it's just they never get old
like you would think as a host you might
just be watching it being like another
person is on there but it's like we stop
on the brakes and go wow that's so good
like it feels i've caught myself like
tearing up on the brakes and being like
that is amazing and i think it's cool
here at ramsey we have fans of your fans
and it's like we are such fans of the
people and everybody has such a unique
story that it still hits us every time
well
with all of the the drama that's created
by the caller some of it is created by
us
some of the controversy george
got to be a part of that the other day
ken and it was really special rachel and
i were on the air and we had a katie
calling from kentucky i remember all the
details haiti from kentucky murray
kentucky okay oh yeah this is this is my
memory is searedness yeah he said one of
the stupidest things
he dug himself it has a name now it's
called horse gate and so we've
officially named it
and we're on the call with her and she's
going hey my side hustle was horseback
riding my horse is injured i need ideas
for side hustles so we're giving her
some ideas hey there's a local i'm
googling there's a local walmart in your
area you can go make some good money
there you can dogs well it's a real
rural area she's it felt like she was
just on the justification train
and had left the station so we're
getting to the end of the call she makes
thirty four thousand dollars a year we
find out she's a hundred and twenty
thousand dollars in debt and so at the
end we're coming up to the break and i
go katie i'm gonna challenge you could
you sell the horse
and she then go well i've had it for 11
years and and i went to katie the horse
doesn't even know your name
and rachel's looking to her she was just
in horror and shocked like the most
intuitive animal you could ever own
well but i think technically george is
correct the horse doesn't know where
he's gonna tell him
i just want to stand up for this
level she's like no this horse you know
you act like you call the horse a bed oh
you know all this george like oh katie
doesn't even know your name go to pray i
was like oh my gosh here's the thing i
have a soul i've got two dogs everyone's
coming at me going would you sell your
dogs i thought my dogs don't need a farm
my dog isn't worth twenty thousand
dollars your dog is not injured my dog's
not pills and that you're not 120 in
debt i don't know i know we all knew i
know
i agree with you heard about her future
and i went she's never gonna get out of
debt of this right if she doesn't change
her in stole the horse yeah she's stuck
because of the horse i know and so we
came back from the break i tried to
couch it all it was not working and then
you said
you said i wonder how much the horse
would go for you know and you're like i
looked it up you know what i can't
remember 11 000.
yeah and he was like
you're she said the horse is 30 000
and then he said katie
the horse is worth more than you
i was like you
literally just kept digging the horse
grave and i was about to fall into it
now i got to back off a horse is not
worth more than a person george you see
i told me i said i said net worth rachel
not worthwhile it's worth it because
katie you're a negative 120. there's
been some regrets in how we say things
on air that then are plastered on
youtube forever you can't change and so
there are some regrets and she emailed
even that weekend with pictures of her
and her prize winning horse so we even
wrapped it up but i mentioned i said
this to john yesterday i said i i care
about her future more than her feelings
but i could have cared about her
feelings too
in hindsight i know and horse people are
very passionate people and you went
after the horse community passionate is
a very kind word yes
we've been trolled for days yes so
there's now a youtube channel called
george campbell's horse and i comment on
all of our videos just saying hey
hey
it's great
it's great
katie i'm gonna give you a hard
challenge could you sell the horse
would you do it
i can't
why not
um i've had this horse 11 years
and katie katie katie there's other
horses out there it doesn't even know
your name
there's more horses for you on the other
side listen i want katie to win my gosh
she's got a mess to clean up i'm doing
whatever it takes i'll get another horse
later this is the ramsay show
[Music]
the smartest thing i've ever done with
money was buy an engagement ring for
stacey i would say the smartest thing
that i've done with money is invest
early on in life the smartest thing i've
ever done with money is pay off my house
early i just thought you have to live
with a mortgage payment forever and it
goes with you to the grave when i found
out you can just pay it off early and
then live a life without a mortgage
payment it changed everything highly
recommend it the smartest thing i've
ever done with money is increase my
generosity to the outrageous level the
smart thing i did with money was um i
paid into my health insurance so both of
my kids could be born at the local
hospital the smartest thing i've ever
done with money was when over a half a
million dollars in scholarships to pay
for my education
so dave over 30 years of doing radio a
lot of life has happened the world has
changed america has gone through some
things i mean you think about 9 11 great
recession
covid student loan crisis and you're
there every day taking these calls with
people in the middle of some really
intense economic times what was that
like the the first time
that the nation shut down
that when i was on here
was um
the first story started rolling out
while we were live on the air
on the columbine shooting
[Music]
and um
it was a shut everything down
uh all all news everything went to that
all
networks stopped and went to
breaking news
whatever the other programming was on
radio tv everything stopped and went to
it
it was it was iconic at the time and um
and you know we're getting live
updates while we're on the air
and you know we've got to sit there and
make a decision are we going to
just keep talking about our stuff and
not
address it but it it had put full stop
on everything so we just stopped and
started taking calls from people and how
they were feeling about it and
what else was going on and um
you know just giving people a
place to be angry and sad and
all the emotions that we all had that
day
9 11 happened at 8 30 in the morning
and so we had
a little time because we go on in the
air in the afternoon
to figure out how big a deal that was
and we knew that it was shut down and we
actually pulled the plug on the show and
ran
one of the network
news feeds over our network i think we
went back on the air probably on
thursday or friday and again we just
gave people a place to
express themselves
and the anger
uh the revenge the uh
all you know the fear all of it and then
the stock market you know they had of
course it's
wall street literally is in the shadow
of the towers and so it shut down wall
street because they had
dust and rubble in front of the building
so they reopened the following monday
and we knew the stock market was going
to dive
it dropped 500 points in 14 minutes it
was crazy
and so he knew that was good so we're
preparing people
you know on friday thursday and friday
going mark it looks like they're going
to reopen stock market monday just be
ready let me tell you what it's going to
do it's going to go down but it's you
know and everybody's like oh see they've
they've crushed our economy with the
towers and no they haven't no they
haven't it's just stock market is just
it's a drama queen so you just got to
ride with it and and
um all the everybody's reporting
headlines major newspaper headlines big
print stock market takes dive after
terror type
you know and it was the leading story
for
the you know 48 hours after that
um
i couldn't find a single news outlet
that reported
when it completely returned 57 days
later
back to where it was not a single one
but we did
we talked about that a lot because we
told people hang on it's like we always
do hang on you're playing the long ball
you're playing long ball and it came
back so those those were
dramatic lengthy
things uh that have happened and then
you know you have other
big news events since then that
kind of got to sit back and go is this
big enough to
even address it
we even used to have a stock market
report at the close of the day because
stock market closes by the time we get
off the air and we would take a live
thing at the one of the last few
segments of the show and report with
stock you know dow closed up they'll
close down
and we figured out
people were not listening to us for that
they don't care
and i i was probably the only one that
cared and when i quit reporting it i
quit checking it too so i don't even
care
yeah it's definitely a show about hope
and the common thread there is you know
it's kind of a voice of truth in a world
gone mad we're there to be like the
sky's not falling stay calm it's gonna
be okay and those principles you know
ride throughout different topics now
from ken with career and christina with
the student loan crisis and you know
delony with kovid and ken with the great
resignation we're seeing you know money
touches all of these different areas in
a big way and we're expanding the show
as well to cover more topics have you
guys seen any uh trends or threads in
the calls you've been taking the last
few years
the student loan crisis is out of
control i mean 1.75 trillion dollars in
student loan debt and we're seeing
people just completely weighed down with
this debt i mean they tell students
going to college this is good debt
you'll be able to pay it off easy and
it's like what we're saying is it's not
that easy we're seeing people who do
have a lot of regret with it so um it's
just crazy that at this point it is
still such an issue but thankfully you
know we get to help people walk through
it and kind of change their mindset that
this isn't something that you have to
carry with you for the rest of your
lives like this is something that you
can attack and attack it fast and get it
gone for good
yeah a thread that touches all of this
is we tell people that you can happen to
your life it doesn't just have to happen
to you you can take control you can have
agency and that touches every single
piece of this from mental health to
career to relationships to money it's
amazing how that is really the
foundation because we're going to help
people gain control and they're going to
do it they're the hero we're just the
guides yeah i think when we look back
many years from now on the pandemic era
i think we could say that it was the
great reflection
i think because of obviously in the
early days and depending on what you
believe about it where you live
certainly people had to confront their
mortality you know
and then i think the other thing that
developed over time is people had to
confront how little they control
you know it was like i can't like if the
whole world shut down over this and the
way i do my life the way i do my work
changed radically and it did
then i think people had to confront i
don't control very many things and i
think they began to look for places in
their life where they could control
things and certainly in the space of
work you talk about what's changed so
much
uh i think people realize you know what
i want to work in a place where i feel
valued
i think that was a big knee-jerk
reaction i i don't want to be a
commodity i want i want to know that
that my company that my leader values me
i think i want to do something that i
enjoy i spend the majority of my life at
work and i just realized wait a second
there's a different way to do work and
so you talk about things like remote
work certainly existed prior to the
pandemic
but phrases like hybrid work where
companies are still trying to figure out
all this and then you get workers trying
to figure out how do i want to do my
work where do i want to do my work how
does it fit and so i think that's a big
reaction to
the fact that people are now going i can
control some things you know we early on
in the pandemic we did a wonderful thing
called the a night of hope and we just
talked about it's something that davis
said for decades control the
controllables and so i think we've seen
a big shift certainly in the workspace
and how am i going to spend that
majority of my time
and it's all about what can i control
and i'm going to try to do that and i
think that's something that has
definitely shifted as a result of the
pandemic yeah i agree with that i think
after 9 11 one of the comments i heard
most regularly by people who were
two three decades older than me was they
kept saying this doesn't happen here it
was a psychological shift that oh this
could happen right
and i think very i think you nailed it
again i think through the pandemic
people
had to confront
oh the government can just tell us we
all can't go to work
right like i didn't know that that was a
thing
um
oh this many people can just get sick
like this many
i don't think any of us were going about
our days thinking this was a possibility
and like you mentioned i think it's you
really realize oh i control very very
little and it's disconcerting
psychologically right and then you have
to build back okay what can i control
and then suddenly you start to realize
wait a minute i can control a whole lot
more than i thought i could right so
it's this dip
and uh so i think that's like that's the
common thread i can't do this i can't do
this yeah tell your mother-in-law you're
not coming for thanksgiving it's you can
and it's like oh
you know what i mean so we're giving
people hope but you gotta you gotta ride
right through it with them right yeah
and on the money side we've seen i mean
dave you've seen a lot of money trends
come and go we talk about this in the
building wealth event all the get rich
quick schemes we're now seeing pop back
up and they're in new ways now rachel
with you know cryptocurrency and nfts
and nothing down real estate just made a
comeback it seems like everything has
changed but also nothing has changed the
mentality is still there well and the
voices speaking into it now
are greater i mean you look at social
media you look at tick tock you look at
youtube i mean all these places that now
anyone
can have a platform and a voice and i
think that's what's unique about this
about ramsey is that there's been 30
years of groundwork of something proven
so when something kind of flashy pops up
that looks like a good idea
and that everyone jumps on it we're the
ones usually tapping the brakes being
like let's just wait and see how this
plays out crypto let's wait till this
plays out nfts i literally read an
article today
and it was talking about all the
celebrities that had come out endorsed
and it was like
you know so-and-so came out indoors and
then the nfts went and they lost 99 of
their value you know you're seeing all
this happen and we're the ones steady
through the trends and the flashiness
yeah to say hey let's just let's just
hang there was an andy griffith
clip i saw and i was like this is like
literally for our time and i'm gonna
butcher it but basically he's saying
yeah this man is saying to him
you know well let the kid decide let the
kid decide and andy's like no no no kids
will always go with the flashy thing oh
they'll always pick up the flashy thing
because they're thinking only for the
moment
but i know what that flashy thing can do
long term
and i was like it's just so good cause
these flashy things you know just pop up
and we're the i feel like hopefully the
voice of breeson and the culture are
saying
oh it sounds good in the moment just
hold off yeah hold on think long term i
have said if you follow the trends you
fall for the traps and that's what we're
seeing with these younger generations
because there's super targeted marketing
that's going hey dude all you need is
ten dollars you're gonna get ten
thousand next week i promise or how
about jason bourne telling you the
fortune
favors the brave
sign up i mean when jason bourne says
that you trust jason bourne right yeah i
mean how do you back in the day good
will hunting when it was just radio
there wasn't and we do know that jason
bourne is not a person he's a character
in the movie
you know this i don't we
hey don't on can i this is this is the
the mental health guy asking you like i
i i really want to know this
um how's your mental health
i have a firm grasp i'll stop any time i
want i have a firm grasp on dave's
mental health it's not great um
why is it so hard
the path is clear it's not
it's like how do you lose weight diet
and exercise it's not it's not
challenging yet it is a perplexing
trillion dollar industry
live on less than you make
um there's not a scheme in seven to ten
years you can have everything you have
in your life paid off and you'll be on
the road to being a millionaire which
means you can give wildly and your kids
are gonna be okay
why is that message so i guess unsexy
and why is it so
hard to follow because it just doesn't
sound challenging
i think we're wired to search out the
fastest easiest way
we want the um the most efficient
fastest easiest way
the problem is is that when you
believe a lie
on what is the fastest easiest way
that that's where the issue comes in and
so you're just
but uh the bible says that no discipline
seems pleasant at the time but it yields
a harvest of righteousness
no one likes
every one of us have a kid inside of us
that wants what we want right now
i want it i want it now i deserve it i
want the cereal mommy i'm going to throw
a fit on the cereal aisle right we all
have that serialized kid inside of us
and
but adults devise a plan and follow it
children do what feels good adults
understand there's a price to be paid
that one definition of emotional
maturity is the ability to delay
pleasure for a greater good
and um
and if you
dare tell someone that is immature
emotionally whether they're 52 or 12
that they need to delay pleasure
they will come back at you with every
bit of their intellect
every bit of their uh anger
um
every bit of whatever
call you names everything else because
you have dared to
call out that the the mythology that
they're the the path they're honest that
they're dialing into
uh
it's not gonna work for you and so you
know anytime we challenge
uh
that then they come back at you and go
oh well you're just the people say a cup
of coffee a day
and you'll be rich
and we're like uh
yeah it's an example it's a math example
calm your butt down but um
but you know the it's but the point is
when you spend
ten dollars or fifteen dollars a day on
coffee
and then you have your student loans
still 14 years later and you're still
paying it then something's off i mean
you're you've not addressed what's going
on and so but
again you're that that's where the
criticism comes back is you dare call
people out on their stuff
uh because you love them and you want
them to do better
but you get a very childish
reaction and we all have the ability to
do that me too yeah uh don't tell me i
can't do something i i you know and so
we all have that ability to rise up
against that but um i i think it's just
immaturity yeah more than anything and
and
when you the truth thing is when you
tell people the truth about how to get a
job
or the truth about how here's how you do
this relationship or hear the truth
about what you've got to do with your
money they hear it even if they don't
like it
it touches truth has a way of getting to
you
and so you know and they know you love
them
and we love them we care about
[Music]
i always want listeners to come away
with a plan that they can execute which
gives them hope i want you to laugh i
want you to have hope all of that but i
also just want you to learn because
that's why we're here is to help the
caller that we are talking to but also
all the listeners the millions of people
out there and so if you can take
tidbits of information apply it to your
life and it changes the outcome
of where you are financially
that would make me really happy when
people watch or listen to the show what
i hope they walk away with
is a little bit of confidence that they
can take that right next step with money
no more excuses ignorance was bliss
until they got the advice from us and
they went i know too much i know what i
got to do now my hope for them is that
they walk away with clarity realizing
that there is a clear path from where
they are to where they want to go and
that they now have confidence to
actually take the steps necessary to
have transforming actions in their life
to get them where they want to go when
someone watches the show i hope they
walk away with hope knowing that no
matter what they're going through or how
overwhelmed i feel that there's always a
way to get through it if you are willing
to push through for a season and focus
you can find a way through any situation
somebody sat there and listened to what
i'm going through what i'm experiencing
and yeah they poked fun at me yeah they
we all laughed together yes we cried
together
but they showed up and they listened
and nobody else in my life listens to me
but they did
that's what i hope they come away with
so the impact of this stuff dave over 30
years you're we're now seeing the fruits
of that generationally i mean you meet
you know what we call financial peace
babies which is the kids of parents who
went through financial peace who have
done this plan now they're growing up in
this culture you meet baby steps
millionaires who follow the baby steps
and go oh my gosh dave i'm a millionaire
did you find that starting to trend over
the last few years yeah we had to be
real careful to name them financial
peace babies because some guy got on
there and he goes i'm a dave ramsey baby
no you ain't
if i'm like no you're not either
change that phrasing so yeah we're going
to call you a financial peace baby oh
yeah okay i get it
yeah whoo
ramsay baby
no you're not a ramsey baby no no you're
not so
from this point forward i'm gonna refer
to everybody's ramsay baby
just just be known that that's not okay
okay yes yeah but it's that's the thing
i didn't see that if we did it long
enough we would see
the third generation now
starting to move it's amazing you know
and uh because some of them are you know
they get it in high school in the hot
weather high school curriculum or
whatever and
you know we'll see that uh with the work
that uh that we're doing in the career
area we'll see that with the work we're
doing in the mental health areas too
yeah um i mean it won't take but about
10 years and you'll start to see
the generational
effect of it um
but you know and it's odd that we used
to say it was kind of a tagline but it
was the truth change your family tree
change your family tree and if you learn
how to do relationships you change your
family tree if you learn how to get into
a career that is satisfying
you uh more is caught than taught rachel
says so the kids are watching they're
gonna
go oh wait a minute maybe i can make
more money not less
and do something i love and not have to
be in a toxic environment wow i don't
have to go i'll make less so that i'm
happy that's that's a bunch of garbage
so we have we can break all that
put that truth out there and break that
the mythology off of them and then
another generation comes along yeah and
uh we're all here you know carrying the
torch and in 2021 there was a very
intentional shift from the dave ramsey
show to the ramsay show and it's slight
we just took out four letters but it
means a whole lot more what is the
future of the show to you
well that was a part uh that was the
uh
one of the last major steps of uh
moving the brand off of a single person
too many
um
you know we added all the personalities
over the years and um
we had intended to start putting
personalities more on the air with me
uh in uh 21 then covet happened
and so we went okay we have to as a
group get on the air and talk to people
in john's case be able to calm them down
and his trauma
background you know people were
traumatized and so you know
facts are your friends can't function in
fear critical thinking skills break down
frontal lobe shut down all that we went
through all that stuff and and so
bringing john and everybody else into
that and going
i get that you're scared we're all a
little scared this is an uncertain time
but here's what it's not here's what
it's not calm down get your thing and so
we accelerated that and got everybody on
the air during that time and then
by the time we had been doing it almost
a year
with everybody on the air as co-hosts
permanent co-hosts permanent co-hosts um
we said all right it's time to go ahead
and just make the change in the name
itself we didn't make a big deal out of
it and so so did no one else it was
great well it's expanded even beyond the
ramsay show now with the ramsey networks
we've got a whole network of shows with
the ken coleman show and the rachel cruz
show the dr john dolone show the fine
print and it's amazing how it really is
like succession we're looking at it
right now as we start to enter these
different areas and and help so many
more people there's a lot more people to
reach out there and uh job security the
world is still in shambles so there's
plenty of work to be done for all of us
so that's the good news and the bad news
but as we wrap here what would you guys
say to the person regardless of their
situation it's money it's career it's
life relationships they feel stuck right
now and they don't see a way out what do
you just wish you could say to every
person i would say that there's hope
that no matter how dark your situation
is or how overwhelmed you feel there's
always a way there's always a way
i i i would say that uh that stuck as a
choice
uh i i i'm not in any way minimizing the
the feeling of being stuck or the
circumstances where someone feels is
that because i take it quite literally
you know i remember i would tell someone
to to put themselves from home when they
feel stuck financially
uh emotionally uh
professionally oh i can't get out no
one's gonna give me a shot whatever and
i'd say all right uh first we're not
gonna panic you know we're gonna go okay
there is a way christina said so
beautifully there's a way and that's
what we specialize here at ramsey
solution is a clear path
there are steps that you can take and
you can get unstuck so stuck is a choice
so once you move into this all right
there is a way i got to find the way and
then when i find the way so that's
clarity now i know i can walk the way
and i can begin to shift from i feel
hopeless
and helpless and i go to
i am confident
that if i do the little things and
struggle as we were talking about
earlier embrace the struggle i can get
unstuck and i think that that's it's the
mindset to realize that if you think
you're stuck it's because you've chosen
uh to believe that you are hopeless and
helpless and you're not yeah it starts
with that paradigm shift where you gotta
go i gotta think about this differently
before i can even believe it's possible
and take action and once you think about
it differently go i'm not going to stay
this way where i am right now is not
where i have to be a year from now six
months from now 10 years from now and
when you have that vision for your life
you've got that powerful why man it'll
light you up and so that's what i want
for everyone watching yeah i would say
look for
options and look for people because i
think when you're stuck and there is
hopelessness it feels like there's
there's no options or if there is it's
just one and that one option is terrible
it's the only thing
i can only do this i can only do that
whether it's you know with relationships
or you know money or just like it's just
that and i'm like there's always options
so even when someone calls on the show
and they're like yeah i've got i have to
do this i'm like no you don't think
about abcde i mean there are options out
there so i would say just
stop
look for options and then look for
people because i think when you are
um actually our past we're talking about
this on sunday when you're discouraged
it can be a very lonely place and you
and you draw in and you talk about this
a lot but i was like get people around
you and whether that was people are us
and you tune in and listen to the show
um
but really encouraging you yeah people
in your life that can walk with you that
can hear you
uh that can actually maybe bring you
options of things that you you aren't
thinking about because when you are
stuck
it's like a tuttle vision so have
find those options and find those people
to walk with you yeah yeah it's i i echo
that i think
the the longer i'm doing these shows the
less relevant my quote-unquote all the
articles i've read are
it's the fact that i'm a guy that
they're slowly starting to trust this
guy who loves me and he'll be honest
with me and they'll lay out this long
three or four minute problem
and it's like
it's just this and they go oh
and i have to remember that in my life
that when i get stuck when i see a big
problem i need to
stop like you just mentioned i got to
stop and i got to reach out to somebody
i got to make sure somebody sees me and
then that's going to be my path out and
so i've got
the listener watching this show remember
this we're with you it's not us versus
you it's us with you and
the more we can create an environment
where people feel with us and that we
feel we are able to sit with them i
think that um these shows will continue
to do well um no hope deferred
[Music]
makes the heart sick
and i've been there
most people have been there
where you feel stuck or you feel
panicked or you feel
trapped in a certain
one decisions all i can do or have two
possible decisions both of them are bad
two options and you've we've all been
there that that hopelessness is
so debilitating
the rest of that verse says but
hmm
and that's a big word
when desire comes
it is the tree of life
so when you end your hopelessness
when you in your moment
connect with people
find a plan
know what the next step is
fog starts to clear
and
you say desire
now desire has come
i am choosing
to use that word that you used earlier
agency i'm choosing to
what john would call take locus of
control i'm choosing to say i can
control the controllables i'm choosing
to say yeah this is a bad deal
but
it's not forever and it all comes down
to
choosing
to change
when
desire comes
it is the tree of life
and that's the only person we can't help
on this show is the one that won't
choose desire
instead they they want to become
defensive
and they want to intellectually build a
set of walls around their life
emotionally build a set of walls around
their life that say see i can't win i'm
a victim i it's impossible for me to win
i'm stuck someone else is going to have
to fix this i can't fix it um and we
can't help that person
until we can get them some desire throw
them some desire over that wall and get
in there and then they start to knock
down the victim walls and they start
moving from victim to victor
well dave speaking of choosing i'm
speaking on behalf of the group and
millions more thank you for choosing
many decades ago to step into the
spotlight to give people hope and money
and now all areas of life grateful for
you all honored to do this incredible
work with you and make an impact thanks
for being here